Hãy nhóm tình cần số tình để chán lảo lên,
có có lần hỏi nhớ anh em bỏ lảo hất làm điều.
Để các nổi những anh em là
cùng nhau tổ chức đi cấp.
Chào con kia là tụi là cấp dẫn này.
Các bạn sẽ là đoàn bỏng trời sau.
Các bạn hướng hôm nay không có một nông này.
Để bước bỏ sẽ.
Đóc hôm nay là bước đập này thì giải trà bảo là lối em có dở lần gió.
Sách định giống trường thuần này để tổ thác.
Cái nhóm sau đó phân công dù vụ thu thái,
tôi chúng bị điều,
gắn tay và xem ấy,
đồng thời thống nhất dùng ngắn bỏ tốn ngay sau khi thực hiện vụ cục.
Tụng tình cần số tình để chán hảo lên,
tôi mới lên hỏi nhóm,
anh em vẫn hảo hất làm điều.
Để các nổi những anh em là
cùng nhau tổ chức đi cục.
Chào khi đập tụi của lời cục dành này,
tôi có gà xe để đồng mỏng,
giời sẵn, giời gà mơ hướng,
hâm đá của cuộc một năm nay.
Để vực bỏ xe.
Đúng không em gặp đây thì giải gà,
giải gà là lỗi em có dở lần dỏ lời.
Để qua mặt tụi quán kích nền,
các đúng tình đến phụ thu thái,
phán quán vánh vý tăng tên quà phật chuyển.
Công số tên quà quán bị thú dữ,
các đúng khai đặc cầm cố bán để chán nào và tưu xa cá nhân.
Cơ quán cắn sẽ điều trả công em thành phút chi Minh tiếp tục
tụi thú số tài sáng của lại bị tổ thán.